when he said what he said about you know
jesus i'd still was before he passed
away male 1
and jenna he ended up
something to to be fair i have noticed
and that is
and after the the cowboy fight that he
won is uh sinead o'connor is she like
considered the queen
of pop music over there at the end god
god
yes he was like you know you know he
praised god
you hook up with uh conor mcgregor i
mean what would you tell him a man like
that
who has everything right i want life
that's the life i live
whatever i want whenever i want this
to speak irish
no not really i found the most i i was i
was very keen on learning it when i went
to ireland but i found that
most of the irish themselves don't speak
it either so i see
i never i never put in the time to learn
it unfortunately but irish
irish people have that unique that
unique uh accent
yeah yeah especially when you go down
more south towards cork in these areas
okay but you lit so you lived in uh
you've lived also in ireland
yeah i was there for like five and a
half years i'm still
more or less should be you know uh back
and forth
but with the you know the pandemic that
happened and i was here with my family
so we ended up just staying
alhamdulillah did you ever cross paths
with our friend conor mcgregor
no no no not not nothing uh in person
anyways no
well inshallah god willing he can maybe
uh i think uh
possibly uh somebody can get this uh
show to him we actually did some
programs before and
we want to talk to you about because
you're of irish descent
and inshallah god willing we can derive
some benefits from that
and you're also somebody who i i hear
started training uh
some of the jiu jitsu is that correct
i started maybe about three or four
years ago alhamdulillah
how's that going uh it was going pretty
good but i hurt my knee about a
probably about a year ago i had surgery
actually here in turkey yeah i tore my
meniscus so
i'm trying to wait until i get back on
the mats and shallow what's up well now
welcome that's a warrior's car now
welcome to that's the risk with training
huh
but you got that from from actually from
training huh you toward the meniscus was
it yeah
i i i was training in in qatar and qmma
there with the brothers
and it twisted the wrong way and then it
was okay for some time but then
and after the pandemic i was you know
trying to do some some uh
running in the hills here in turkey and
it just uh just popped you know
[Music]
and then when you especially now when
you go to pray right when you go when
you're sitting in in the position there
does it yeah yeah so kind of actually i
made a video about that actually one of
the most difficult things that i faced
was not being able to make subdued you
know that didn't cross my mind
you know how much of a blessing that
actually is
is difficult to make subdued i had to
pray and over so many months in a chair
and um it was just it was really
difficult not being able to you know to
prostrate and put your head on the
ground subhanallah i hear you
it was really that was the biggest
emotional tear you know
yeah no that's when you have that knee
injury yeah it really affects that
subhanallah but uh many people don't
know we've met we've actually
how long has it been we met in uh at the
peace conference do you remember that
that's it i was gonna see if you
remember that man it's been 12 years
about 12 years
and almost 12 years now yeah and i
remember when we met that you said you
didn't have your equipment and you
wanted to film with me but you said
we'll set up something else
so here we are now 12 years later and
you're finally doing it myself here we
are 12 years later yeah
yeah i remember i remember talking with
you hanging out a little bit yeah
alhamdulillah
god almighty allah reunited us
so you remember if we can take it back i
mean again we don't want to kick a man
when he's down right and you obviously
followed did you did you get a chance to
uh
kind of see the ups and lows the highs
with conor mcgregor
yes the panel line if you look at it
it's very interesting
um he was very successful and and the
people i know who
actually people were training with him
and knew him from before
he was someone who was very simple and
very humble uh but unfortunately like
many people when you know people
are successful that a lot of times it
goes it goes to their head
and you know he became you know very
arrogant and i made the video
i saw that you had posted on it was uh
before the kb fight
um you had posted it i think on on on
your channel on
the dean show youtube channel and
there's some other channel i think like
illum feed and this and they posted it
and it got actually got
if you look at all of the platforms it's
very close to a million views and even
it's the most viewed
video on my own channel as well uh over
a hundred thousand
so it's a panel of the um topic was why
i hate conor mcgregor i
didn't really want to you know the word
hate i don't like to use it i don't like
to hate people
but what what he said to me was so
appalling about jesus
i found it very offensive as a muslim
and you know and i put that out there
you know to people know
is that you know we don't just get upset
as muslims if someone talks negatively
about
our beloved prophet muhammad but also
when people
talk about uh other prophets as well we
don't accept this as muslim subhanallah
so when he said what he said about you
know jesus
versus jesus in the earth and i'll tell
you what there's not a man alive that
can be
me but jesus ain't alive is he so i
don't know maybe he could come back from
the dead not i don't know i'd still
be able to whip his you know whatever if
he were to come back he would whip him
and then um then calling himself a god
me and jesus are killed i'm killed with
all the gods gods recognize
gods and saying though that god's
recognized other gods
and this and i i i was i was shocked you
know someone who you know
i was really inspired by his story you
know ireland wasn't known for mixed
martial arts you know
known for boxing yes mixed martial arts
no he's someone who came up from nothing
and worked hard and
you know he's really dedicated and he
was good man he was really good you know
and he had a lot of good fights i mean
it went to his head and he caught
himself another guy and i actually said
to the brothers then
i said he's going to get exposed i said
i said allah is going to humiliate him
and i mentioned the story
if you remember the video or not about
the titanic yeah and they said even god
can't sing this and that's exactly
you know what happened i didn't think
nate i was a bit scared you know i know
nate diaz i think he's a better fighter
all around you know obviously his ground
game
even his boxing what have you but i
didn't know he would be able to beat him
with nine days notice you know
but second round sure enough he choked
him out you know
in a really bad way you know that so
that's the humiliation
that comes when you when you reach that
that level of arrogance subhanallah
and then obviously after that you know
obviously he came back with khabib was
humiliated and then his last knockout
was humiliated but something to
to be fair i have noticed and that is
and
after the the cowboy fight that he won
you know rather decisively and quickly
um he praised god at the end i don't
know if you noticed that enough yes
at the end yes he was like you know you
know
he praised god i think uh your video our
videos i made some videos also towards
him
maybe uh maybe actually i was gonna make
a video about it but i know i made so
many videos about this i have
other things i'm focusing on but i
thought about that you know maybe that
you know that that uh the khabib
actually you know humbled him you know
and
and it really had an impact on him he
thought about it
um you know he said in the fight maybe
it's all business maybe he's just trying
to sell more stuff
you know but everything has limits you
know even if you're trying to make more
money or sell more things
there's certain things that you just
don't do and perhaps he he realized that
he had a lot of court cases as well
you know issues with females and now he
seems he's trying to be more of a
devoted husband devoted father
um he's you know you you saw before the
in the in the pre-fight with dustin
poirier
you know someone who's very respectful
honestly he was very well behaved
and what he was saying was was you know
good and positive
and he was positive after the defeat as
well you know so sometimes alhamdulillah
like you said at the beginning don't
kick a man when he's down
you know sometimes people learn you know
it doesn't mean that you know someone
made a mistake in the past that we have
to hold him accountable
if someone changes and that's what we
want for you know all of mankind is
is for their good and they're better but
obviously something you know what he had
reached
it's something that you know what wasn't
any it wasn't acceptable even many of
the irish people people think that
you know all irish people support him
and i think i mentioned that in the clip
as well
that um you know the people don't like
that that you know
you have certain uh certain class of
people in society which is not
a really respectable class of course
they might like stuff like that
but i mean the majority of the people
don't like that irish people they're
very nice very humble people
and i think you've been to ireland
yourself and you've seen you know very
very nice people alhamdulillah so they
they
many i speak to many of my irish
non-muslim friends and neighbors
even those who i trained with there and
none of them liked you know his
shenanigans and the things he was doing
and didn't didn't feel comfortable about
you know that representing you know
ireland and irish people yeah we saw
that what you said
that was what really just shocked us
when he was uh
calling himself kind of like a god and
then he would
whip so and so himself who we take
strong offense to
disrespecting jesus peace be upon him
who we love is one of the mightiest
messengers that god ever sent not as a
god or little son of god but as a
messenger just like all the other
messengers that god sent
for humanity uh and then we that was
like appalling you know it was like
wow what happened you know how how could
he say such
you know derogatory things and
blasphemous things and whatnot
and then you even had christians who
were calling him out on that and
and then he kind of changed his way he
went away from that and then it seems
like uh
he started started praising god he
started saying god bless he started
saying you saw that also right he kind
of made a shift
right and then and then he went from
that
that really stuck out to me after yeah
and then and then he went also then from
disrespecting
his f his uh people opponents to
actually showing some respect
he started to after the khabib fight
right he started with cowboy and
all the way up to this last fight he
started being a lot more respectful now
and i thought the same thing i thought
what you said i thought he's going to
get humbled
allah god almighty is going to humiliate
him you know
but he can take how should someone i
guess my next question is
how signs you know god almighty sends
these signs you know i mean how could
someone like him
he's i guess he's he's made some some
great improvements
but continue improving you know and and
continue you know really reflecting you
know
what's the purpose of life why am i here
really just thinking beyond the material
things and the possessions because you
see he was at an all-time high
and now it's like look how suddenly uh
quickly things can just change
exactly and and i i think to be honest
from from a fighting standpoint a lot of
it is
you know who he was i mean i think his
his ranking now
and his status i mean it probably even
shouldn't be that high as high as it is
because
uh he's been away i mean there could be
as they say you know the ring rust or
cage rust or whatever it is
i mean that that could you know be some
truth
but you know and you know a lot of times
things happen in life for a reason
there's wisdom behind it
uh you know and you're being humbled you
know things you can go through
difficulties you can face it can make
you a better person and that's that's
what it's all about in the end and it's
not about you know making mistakes
uh you know and you know not making a
mistake excuse me it's about
you know improving when you do make
mistakes and realizing that and becoming
a better person
so i mean i think and generally speaking
he has become a much better person
but obviously now and he perhaps he can
reflect even deeper like you said the
questions other questions deeper
questions
you know what is the true purpose of
life is it this because even you know
what he has from the fame and from the
money
and all of this does that really bring
happiness people
everyone is searching for that's what
they want they think it's going to bring
happiness
but if you look throughout history and
i've given uh khutbahs and lessons about
this before
many of the famous you know singers and
actors and what have you
many of them have died from you know
drug overdose
um even if you look you know the the
king and the queen of pop
and we just you could pop right into
your head there you know both of them
who died you know miserable death so
michael jackson and whitney houston for
example um you know michael jackson the
moschino
the poor guy he couldn't even sleep at
night that's how bad his situation
was you know and he was someone who was
actually looking into islam and
many rumors spread that he accepted
islam but you know apparently he didn't
but he was close and many of his
bodyguards did
um but he he was reflecting he was
thinking he was contemplating he
realized
that this wasn't what it's all about you
know he realizes there's got to be
something wrong here
and he started to uh to search himself
michael jackson but at the end you know
he ended up overdosing
because he couldn't even sleep at night
if he didn't have you know the the these
these meds to be able to sleep at night
whitney houston you know cocaine ended
up drowning in in there
another miserable death and how many
committed suicide
and you know the list goes on and on
subhanallah uh with these these
individuals because
what we see to be happiness and in the
fame and the fortune
and that type of success and whatever
industry you're in we think that's going
to bring happiness
but the reality is is it doesn't it and
it just brings
you know more challenges that you're
going to be challenged with and
and and and many people it you know
drives them away from happiness
and we we hope inshallah tala that this
will also be a time for him to search
and him and
not just him and others to reflect like
you said what is the purpose of life
what are we here
what are we really searching for and
what is real happiness because i can i
can be
you know we can rest assured he's not
going to be a special
uh you know thing where he's gonna find
happiness through this type of lifestyle
where everyone else before him hasn't
and any and and you you speak to them
time and time again to these people
and they're not happy they're not happy
in the situation and this type of fame
and money
it doesn't bring real happiness yeah so
for people that
don't know your story just in a nutshell
you're somebody also
uh tell us a little bit about your past
and what brought you to your level where
you're somebody
dedicated to educating people about
islam you've committed your life to that
uh but before that what were you doing
and how did you get to this point that
you realized based on proof and evidence
that islam
submission to the creator not the
creation that this is the way of life
that is for all huma
all humanity and my story is
is it's interesting from any from that
aspect i was from a
a very good and successful family um
i grew up in the you know the dc area on
the virginia side of the border of
washington dc northern virginia
and subhanallah um my family was like i
said they were very successful but i i
took another path in life
and that was you know um i was very good
in basketball
and a lot of the times you know if you
want to find
the good pickup games and where people
were were better it would be more into
the you know
the inner city type of you know
communities and what have you
so a lot of my friends became um you
know
african-american uh you know guys and
many of them they're they're their
cousins and their brothers and what have
you
and their families were involved in
lives of crime and drug dealing and
stuff like that
so i kind of got you know hooked in that
type of lifestyle you know the
early 90s the the chronic er era you
know i know you kind of in a bit to the
same type of background you know
i got involved in that i got involved in
you know and and even like you know
selling drugs even though i didn't need
that type of lifestyle i was from like i
said it's from a good family
but i just was completely blinded my
father kept trying to you know
get me out of it and tried to help me um
but i was just kind of addicted to that
lifestyle but interestingly enough
one of the people he was actually the
guy used to you know buy my drugs to
sell from
um he lived in dc and his father was a
muslim subhanallah
and you know it's like and that's what
he said those things happen in your life
for you to reflect you know uh to stop
it and allah sends signs man it's just
sometimes people don't realize that
they're there sometimes people don't
reflect enough people
sometimes people are too scared to take
that step
you know but you know for me it was a
clear sign i had always been
intrigued about islam uh because of the
story of malcolm x you know even before
i was muslim
i saw the movie with denzel washington i
read the book completely
so yeah and obviously there's something
i had in my mind about islam and muslims
and i saw how it had an impact on his
life and i know i felt that i was
someone who had you know
i had no direction in my life i was you
know i was really i i could feel that i
was astray
even like my body you know what doing to
my body with the drinking and the
smoking and the smoking of the weed and
i just felt you know i i wasn't feeling
good inside because i used to be an
athlete used to be involved
you know you know playing basketball all
the time i was always in good health
so i could feel my body deteriorating i
could feel you know i wasn't in a good
state
so i i needed something but i did i
didn't know islam would would be
it with that i mean just but it was just
like in the back of my mind so one day i
had an appointment with
my friend i was actually you know going
to buy you know some drugs from him
subhanallah
but um he wasn't there he didn't show up
for the appointment his father told me
sit in the basement wait for him
and i heard him listening to some
reciter of the quran in arabic and then
it was translated in english
and i had this curiosity about islam and
you know it's interesting because the
misconception about islam and muslims at
that time
was the issue of you know islam is the
origin of the black man they focused on
the issue of you know nation of islam
and putting that in the media a lot
um i remember there was one of their
preachers named
muhammad he was you know really hardcore
and he was really on the news during
those days and it was like
in towards the end of 1993
and subhanallah so i had this in my mind
that i couldn't be
muslim because i'm white right so i
asked him about this and he obviously
removed that misconception right away
and that's something smaller that the
the enemies of islam they always focus
on
you know spreading that mispropaganda
about islam or the propaganda the
misinformation
the false information about islam and
about muslims because they don't want
people to know the truth subhanallah
so any i asked them about islam and i
read some and i took some books from him
about islam
end up reading about islam al
hamdulillah and there was something
entering in my heart right away
that was in you know the the end of 1993
beginning of 1994.
i accepted islam alhamdulillah then i
was 18 years old at the time in
in in america and about six months later
you know as soon as i became muslim i i
became very intrigued in learning
everything i could about islam
i started to um i
started to study as much as i could
there in america but i realized that the
ones who were the you know the ulema or
the scholars or the students of
knowledge were the ones who actually had
traveled abroad
and that's how i could really benefit
more so i ended up traveling and
studying in sudan
and then i spent uh uh over 11 years in
saudi arabia as well and then i studied
medina and i graduated from
alhamdulillah and uh you know i then i
moved you know to the middle east and
uh in turkey and in also in ireland for
many years
working in dao hamda lecture in both
arabic and english i have you know
lectures regularly in both languages now
alhamdulillah and also many many of the
tv shows like you saw where is filming
for peace tv
and hula tv and other channels as well
alhamdulillah so that that's where i am
you know now alhamdulillah how did the
irish people take to islam how is it
there when they when you talk to them
have you had the experience and
how do they do they look at it something
is foreign you know
how do they perceive islam how is it
taken there in ireland
i i think they look at it as something
four and they don't look at
maybe something you know for them
irish people is that they're you know
very you know
they accept other people you know
they're very nice even if they don't
like you or like what you do they're not
really open towards you about it
so we don't have you know too many like
racial slurs or comments or problems
like that from the irish people
you do have from some of the uh the
lower class you know the
the the i don't know you know what's a
good name for them lowly commenters you
know the people are not really educated
you know
and i'll tell you an interesting story
just that could kind of sum it up for
you
there was a reporter in one of the
famous irish newspapers
she did a an experiment where she put an
alibi a proper islamic dress and then a
cob on she's not muslim
but she just wants to see the reaction
of of the people as a as in
she walked around cork ireland which is
you know this is the the city of the
rebels where my forefathers are from the
mccarthy clan
and um uh you know she walked around the
city for the entire day
and she noticed that most people didn't
bother her didn't say anything to her
she noticed that the people who were
offended by her
were some of the ladies who were kind of
you know i guess you could say out of
their prime
a little bit overweight you know not
really in a good situation
uh you know late 30s early 40s and so
she said this it made us laugh because
my wife who warned me a cop there as
well
she would notice that those same people
were like the only ones you know and
sometimes not really the educated ones
not really doing well in their life
uh probably on social welfare type you
know they were just kind of they would
be the ones who would would kind of look
at you so the reporters
said the same thing and in even
incidents we find if someone did say
something do something it would be from
that
group of people but generally speaking
the people were very nice the government
you know
was amazing the politicians the local
police
um always you know did great work with
them and they were
always very supportive of us and uh
alhamdulillah
so we never had any any issues with that
and they were always very supportive
and very helpful and the general people
always very nice alhamdulillah
i think you know sometimes i i would
joke with my wife because if i were to
wear the islamic um
you know the the dress the long though
and they would see me you know
looking irish wearing that i think that
would be very shocking for them but my
wife would come in with me a cob and
they would
and they would be like they wouldn't say
anything to her right because they
probably assumed that she was someone
who was just like foreign or something
it would know you know what what was her
origin if it was european or not
but when they would see me they would
know obviously that i'm i'm european
i'm irish they could tell from how i
looked and they would see me wearing
that dress they wouldn't really
understand
but we had a lot of good experience
there with the non-muslim community
especially
they were they were very helpful and and
very and very welcoming
is sinead o'connor is she like
considered the queen of pop music over
there and
she's like an icon isn't she and it's
interesting that conor mcgregor
he used her to come out to her song
right and then she go she ends up i mean
i i i haven't met her i i i know that a
lot of
yeah that was very interesting right you
know because she was the one who
actually did the
live it was a live song actually in the
ufc that's the only live
thing i've ever seen done was when when
she did it
i don't know if it's ever been done
before or not but i mean that was the
only time i've ever seen it
when he came out and she was she was
singing for him subhanallah um
and so it's very interesting that she
would accept islam you know now
i i've never met with her yet i haven't
spoken with her i remember when she
became muslim i saw
you know on my social media accounts
everybody was putting my name for her to
contact me
but i haven't actually been in contact
with her yet so hopefully i hope she's
still doing good and
and she's learning more about islam and
she's becoming stronger and better in
chilotana yeah sinead o'connor yeah well
i had her on the program also not to uh
yeah yeah so now you have um
you have also this if you just tell us
about there's always been a good
relationship between
the irish and muslim i mean they have
told us about this potato famine right
where the muslims actually came
and helped the irish there and they
always had this respect for muslims is
that correct
that's true i don't know if all of the
the younger generations actually know
the story for that
uh the place is called rohada and
towards the north
they actually have if you look at their
football club
they actually have the hillel the the
the crescent of the moon
on their on their logo also i believe
the lo the city council as well
or the flag for that area it's also it
has the crescent as well
so you can see that you know that's
something that goes back to that when
the potato famine when they sent you
know the the khalifa of the muslims from
turkey
sent uh you know all of the help even
though he was asked not to from from the
queen of england subhanallah
but he still did it he sent them to help
and then there was something they really
needed and it really helped them out so
they still have a lot of respect you
know
for muslims alhamdulillah also something
very interesting when you look at
the issue of ireland uh not everybody
knows the history of ireland
that you know the ireland was under
occupation for
800 years from from from from england
and you know even until now obviously
the north is still you know uh
uh under occupation as well but in it
six or five five six
of the of the island which is the
republic of ireland now
they've obviously been free for about
almost 100 years now they'll be
celebrating 100 year anniversary
uh soon um the the point is that you
know that you'll find that the irish
people that they're very
when they a lot of issues like for the
muslim issue of palestine for example
you'll find that they're very very pro
and in palestine i know they're always
you know
when something happens in palestine
they're on the street i remember that um
my wife contacted me i was i was
traveling i was on on a dollar trip
and she said that there was an event in
our area in cork and ireland where we're
living at the time
um it was for the people of gaza and you
know she said you know can i go out with
him with some of the sisters
and i said okay bismillah go ahead but
when she contacted me she said the sad
thing was is that
there was not really any muslims there
you know it was all you know non-muslims
were there and supported the
palestinians
and that's because they went through a
very similar situation where they didn't
um
uh you know they did they they 800 years
of occupation subhanallah
i remember i was teaching in dubai for
some time and there was a
palestinian teacher or secretary she and
she said you know you british and
this so one of the irish teachers she
said to her you know we're not british
we're irish
they're they're british the teachers
over there she says it's the same thing
so the irish teacher was quiet and then
she came up she said that the
palestinian
she said you know you israelis and she
was very offended by this she's how
could you say that to us
she said the same thing to an irish
person when you call them english you
know i said that
so she didn't realize that but it's no
this thing that you know
800 years of occupation you know and
then obviously war
and and famine and a lot of difficulties
that the irish people faced
so they feel when they see what's
happening to a lot of the muslims around
the world in their situation
you'll find that you know that they do
you know feel from it and they support
them
and they're very very supportive
alhamdulillah you know beautiful
beautiful people irish people
alhamdulillah
well going back a little bit to uh conor
mcgregor i mean so your last name is a
really
like real uh irish name mccarthy right
when just by saying that name people
know
he's irish right so you have uh one
irishman
actually actually there's any mcgregor
mcgregor is not an irish name by the way
mcgregor is not i mean the mcgregor clan
is actually a scottish plan
it's a scottish clan but he was they're
from the ones obviously his family i
don't know
their history in detail but they
obviously moved to ireland i'm assuming
obviously they married some irish women
throughout the years so i'm sure he has
irish blood but his clan is actually not
an irish clan it's
it's a it's it's a scottish clan
conor mcgregor you call it clans like
that's tribe synonymous with tribes yeah
i tried yeah
yeah yeah so so anything with with a
mick in front of it it's originally mac
and it's interesting i read a book about
you know about irish history irish
families
and they they said like eben they wrote
actually even in arabic and english
like even to the arabs it means even so
and so in the gaelic
or irish language so it means any son of
gregor the son of karthi so this is this
is what it means it's actually
mac and it was made into a um
it was made into an abbreviation and
it's interesting my passport
i grew up all the time in america i was
always mccarthy with the the two c's
connected
for some reason my passport they can you
know they
they they put a space between the two so
it actually means even mccarthy and if
you do the exact translation of it
yeah so any mccarthy obviously we're
from the uh the families from the south
of ireland
and our families actually was the the
royal family or the ruling family
for many years in in the south of
ireland what they call the monster
region was the biggest region of the
south of ireland
the headquarters was quark which is the
city of the rebels and the people of
quark they say this is the
real capital of ireland and because
they're the ones who kept fighting
against the brits as the
the ones in dublin weren't really
fighting during that time until they
obviously
eventually received any receive their
freedom yeah so i don't know exactly
when his family moved over
to ireland obviously they they're irish
now but the clan goes back or the tribe
goes back to
scotland but and the scots and the irish
they're all
as we say you know in arabic benny or
mumma they're all you know cousins and
all related
so if you see a mech in front of any
name he's either irish or scottish one
of the two
there's no there's no no no third unless
they move somewhere else but the origin
goes back either to scotland or to
ireland so if you were to have a heart
to heart if you guys just ran into each
other someone
arranged a meeting you're there in uh
ireland
and you hook up with conor mcgregor i
mean what would you tell them
a man like that who has everything right
he's got the money he's got the fame
but now you want to you know share share
you know something even more valuable to
him that's
just priceless you know this dean how
would you go ahead and start a
conversation with him about it
um you know i i i i tell him you know
to be thankful to his creator and you
know i i think you know he's going
through now is going to be a good
experience for him and like i said
hopefully she'll think
deeper and many people aren't you see
like any um
the nba star who just became muslim was
it uh stephen smith was his name or
yeah stephen stephen jackson jackson yes
who just became this became muslim you
know and that's what he said he said
listen to my heart so that would be my
advice to him and to anyone is to listen
to your heart and to reflect
and to ask that question why are you
here and what is the purpose of creation
you know is it you receive the fame you
receive all the money and he doesn't
have to work another day in his life
so what is the ultimate purpose of life
is this it just tonight just to chill
out on your yacht now and to
to enjoy the finer things in life or is
there a bigger
bigger reason for creation and for us
being here and to reflect on that answer
and
and to look you know to look into sang
for you and look into the same things
she looked into and when she when she
ended up
accepting islam and shalom imagine that
to be able to have all that success
because even with the losses he has and
the amazing career he's had it's amazing
that he's still considered one of the
best of all time even though he's had a
serious downfall in the ring now but it
was just so good before
and you know and became he became the
the major icon of the sport
but yet and he with that success and
with the money and and all of that
if he could find you know the true peace
of heart which which comes from the
submission to your creator
that's where you find the the the true
peace of heart and the true peace of
mind
you know as allah told us
indeed through the remembrance of allah
the hearts find assurance that's when we
truly relax and we truly benefit
and he from knowing the purpose of life
and submitting to the will of our
creator
so we could find that then he would
inshallah have the perfect life
inshallah the success
in all aspects and all spears of life in
shanwa tana do you see this i mean
courage is one thing
okay getting in the ring fighting what
not and
you know people think that's bravery but
do you see a lot of people now when the
truth
comes to you a lot of people now they
buckle down now
okay they might recognize islam is the
truth but it's not the winning team you
know what i mean you got people out
there
they might look into it and they say wow
it's just overwhelming the amount of
evidence islam is not just about blind
faith you know you look into it and you
look at the quran
tamper-free tamper proof you look at all
the you know it's a living miracle you
know
the prophecies you know et cetera et
cetera the life of the last
final ministry prophet muhammad you see
his life there's no way that this man
could have just come
you know on his own bringing all of this
new information
you know and just a simple message
worship the one and only creator of the
heavens and the earth not his creation
just i mean so much evidence but now
people they
a lot of people lack they might have
that courage again to get in and fight
you know if another human being but do
you see a lot of people lacking the
fortitude and courage
to go against the social pressure right
that comes with
now standing up for the truth
yeah exactly and i think it comes from
from two two angles or two aspects
and one of them is any when it comes to
uh
you know accepting the truth and and
like you said many people might read
about it might hear about it
and they might they might believe in it
uh other people sometimes even the
arrogance so much they don't even want
to
to to look for the truth which is even
more scary but a lot of times
it's that courage like you said and i
think it's a beautiful word and even i
remember one of the scholars he talked
about in arabic one time and he called
it
you know the brave step you know and he
said that
many people are are are not any brave
enough to take that step even if you
look for example
uh the the uncle of the prophet muhammad
sallam
who has been very close even closer with
with his nephew muhammad than he was
with
the uh his own sons but yet
when it was it was time for him to take
that brave step
and even though he admitted and openly
that this is the origin of truth he even
has poetry
which praises the religion of his nephew
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam but
yet
when it came time for him to take that
step he wasn't able to do it because of
the
you know what is so-and-so going to say
and what is that going to say and a lot
of times it goes back and the days we
live in it too well
as well to the issue of of not
um the issue of the lust and the desires
people are so into that um that you know
the the having
the lust and the desires but um
is this really what brings happiness and
and and and i think if you look on the
contrary of someone like khabib
who also has reached superstar status
status as well someone who was in a
considered whether him or john jones is
the goat and that could be you know
you could differ on that perhaps you
know if you look at the competition that
he faced
jon jones might be considered a bit
better uh some of our brothers might not
agree but you might
if you look at it it could go either way
when it comes to who's to go but
nonetheless
he's one of the greatest ever and no
one's going to doubt that he has all
this fame but yeah he's someone who's
very simple
someone who's very devoted to his
religion very devoted to his family and
that shows us as well that you can be
someone who can you know
excel it in the affairs of the dunya
someone who can
be um you know and have all the these
millions in success and fame
but at the same time be devoted to your
creator and that's when you that's where
you know say you can't have your cake
and eat it too
yes we say as muslims you can al
hamdulillah because you see we islam
doesn't forbid someone from being
successful
someone from being rich but at the same
time you get to you know
have the best of both worlds when you're
someone who's devoted to your creator
and you feeling that that peace of mind
and peace of heart that everyone's
looking for
but they're looking for in all the wrong
places unfortunately yeah and
uh this is a great time for again conor
mcgregor to really reflect you know
probably somebody who
just was at the top and now you know for
all the
things that are going on in his life uh
you know to really
think about some of these things that
you pointed out but this would also be
amazing how if
let's say by some people think you know
this is uh
god almighty allah's control of the
hearts he can make anything happen so
that'd be amazing let's say he did
uh do what sinead o'connor did right you
never think that she would accept islam
she did allah guided her
conor mcgregor accepts islam you know
and then
him and habib actually turn around
become brothers
wouldn't that be amazing and that's
that's not something strange if you look
throughout islamic history
you have some of the biggest enemies of
islam some of the biggest you know
feuds or wars they had one of them
actually accepted islam and they became
very close
and that's one of the beauties of islam
and the muslims is that they're very
forgiving when it comes to these things
and you would find to allah that if he
if that were to happen that
one of his biggest supporters would be
khabib i can guarantee you that
and this is we've seen it throughout
history time and time again you know
where people forget that and they become
you know brothers as allah said in the
quran and
they that he made you ikuana that he
made you brothers and that brotherhood
there's nothing strong or nothing more
beautiful than that
and then then uh his father khabib's
father actually you know
uh before he passed away may allah
the hearts of muslims are subhanallah
it's not something easy to do but that
shows you
know how you know the really good people
and people that you know
we should look at and take as role
models alhamdulillah
just exactly like after all the insults
and whatnot he still opened his
he opened his house open you know the
doors you know the forgiveness that's
that's really deep and that's what
i think that's something that as well a
lot of times a lot of people who don't
know about
much about islam and the muslims when we
have these type of events
where it's open um you know the open
masjid open house masjid where people
come and actually visit
the masjid a lot of people are
misconceptions when they come and
actually see
you know how muslims live they see and
interact with us and it
it actually changes their their whole
outlook about islam and the muslims
i think it's one of the best forms
actually of giving da'wah is to let
people come and see
come you know have some tea with us come
sit with us come join us in the masjid
come
have some biryani with us at home or
whatever it is that we're you know
with with our neighbors and let them
know you know who we are and what it is
that you know that
that we're doing what it is that we
believe and they'll see that actually
we're not you know these
these strange or weird people that
people make us out to be you know we're
normal people live normal lives we have
you know guidelines that we do not uh
you know and limits that we don't cross
because these are limits that
almighty god sent down to us so that's
why we do this but we have fun we enjoy
life
and we we we're normal people like other
just like anyone else
but we might look at certain things in a
different light you know we could we
could talk to him
for example conor you know if he were to
come we wouldn't have any any proper 12
you know
but we we have you know we have tea and
we have other things we have fun
uh you know that that that he could
enjoy and he could see and he could see
that there's a lifestyle out of that
lifestyle that
that he's living that's actually you
know a very beautiful lifestyle
you made a video about this recently can
you tell us
and i often tell people if you can dig
this you can dig islam because
everything is built on this and this is
what you know not just for conor
mcgregor but for
anybody listening i mean if they can
really truly understand this we call it
tohit the pure monotheism can you just
elaborate on that just for a minute
before we close because this is like
this is the bedrock this is the crust
this is the foundation
and if people can understand this
everything else will simply fall in
place
we focus a lot on that in a lot of our
videos a lot of our lectures issue of
monotheism which is the oneness of god
and of of our creator and and this is
the difference when it comes to any
islam in other religions
and many people might claim one god but
this is the this is the core of islam
and the meaning of islam
which is that there's no deity
no god who has the right to be
worshipped except our creator almighty
god
and this is what we devote ourselves to
and that's what it means to be a muslim
and many people don't
understand you know and some people say
islam is peace no islam is
submission to your creator who created
you and that leaves you
that that submission is going to lead
you to peace so this is the meaning of
the meaning of islamic monotheism where
we devote everything
to almighty allah we devote ourselves to
allah our worship to allah
all our actions are for allah subhanahu
wa tala our main objective as muslims
is for us to do as much good for you
know ourselves
and for our community and for mankind as
a whole and while we live in this life
and with all of this we do with hope
that our creator will be pleased with us
and that he will enter us into the
heaven into jannah and shalom
in the hereafter how do irish people say
god is there a specific did you say god
or is there a particular word that they
use in the irish language
um this i don't know if there's a
different name for it but there's
something very interesting which is
any for jesus they say esau
yes i heard that yeah that's deep yeah
like we say in arabic which is issa
so actually my son who was born in
ireland his name is issa
and um all of the midwives and the
nurses they were very intrigued
about you know what does this name mean
and they were coming to the room to
visit my wife
and they're asking her and um you know
they said that and they told us they
taught us this i never knew that any isa
or jesus is actually issa and the irish
language as well which is pretty
interesting it's by allah
touch upon that also before we conclude
this deep love and reverence many people
don't know do the irish people know that
muslims you
muslim and simply means one who has
submitted his will to god almighty the
creator allah
is someone who has to love and revere
jesus
i mean and accept him not as a god or
literal son of god but as a mighty
messenger
actually i don't think men and whether
irish or not none i think no
muslims actually don't know this and
perhaps we don't do a good enough job in
relaying this message and teaching them
what they don't realize that we're
actually
um you know people who who love uh you
know
issa to the level that we do that's why
i made the video that i made
to make that clear to the people that as
muslims we you know we don't accept this
you know saying negative things about
jesus jesus
may the peace of allah be upon him well
thank you so much i hope your knee
heals up uh good and inshallah we meet
up in person someday
are you going to be back in the states
anytime soon
well you never know inshallah any hope
maybe it shall it'll work out
several tribes have tried to come but
something always comes up so i haven't
made it back yet yeah so inshallah maybe
inshallah all right let's if not then we
can
we can roll here inshallah we got an
affiliation over there that represents
us
uh it's two hours from istanbul there's
one
in istanbul as well they have one as
well gracie jitsu as well yeah
so beautiful beautiful definitely you
can hook me up with them i haven't been
there yet
it was interesting actually actually the
the brother i was training with when i
first came here
it was a dagger as well yeah also
they're pretty tough
i was there i i was training with him
before hurting my knee yeah i was there
i did a seminar actually there
in um in turkey yeah so i'll hook you up
inshallah i'll send you the brothers uh
information information you can hook up
so very good yeah excellent very very
nice talking with you my brother
good to see you after all these years
inshallah we stay in touch
and if you like this episode of the dean
show like this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
you